I had the great pleasure of catching up
with Professor Lissa Sova from
Goldsmith's University she's really
interested in automating the process of
Science and in order to do that you need
to know about logic abduction knowledge
and semantics we see biology is so
complex we we still scratch in the
surface trying to understand and the
there are not enough scientists in the
world to do it and if we can have some
AI help that would be probably a good
thing so my presentation about
reflecting on automation of Science
History of it where we are with it now
how much we can automate now and where
we probably heading towards so I'm
really interested in the philosophy of
science which is to say what is the meta
process that scientists go through when
they do science so science is about
generating theories explanations about
how the world is this way and also how
it's not that way but Science is based
on empiricism which is basically
following the data doing experiments and
trying to Discount hypotheses but we
still have this chicken and egg problem
which is where do the hypotheses come
from and this is very related to the
bias ference trade-off in in machine
learning um generally we can't start
from a blank slate we can't start with
nothing we need to have some World
Knowledge to structure our search
process and then we run into trouble you
know how much should we seed the system
with prior and World Knowledge there are
so many things in our physical world
that it just feels like we should encode
it into our systems it' be a waste of
time not to but then there are some some
things that we feel that the system
should learn but if we bias the system
too much then we might acre a kind of
approximation error because there are
things that our system just won't be
able to search because we've biased it
too much so there's always this tradeoff
between having the flexibility to find
new things versus cutting down the
search base you the next big step will
be when we will be able to consume more
knowledge so not just data but if we
start using what we
no specific knowledge is a major source
of machine and human intelligence and
will suffice even with simple inference
again to reflect so if you take AI
system it's mostly taking lots of data
in the best case it will take lots of
different data put it together and then
it outputs some predictive model or
something else or I don't know piece of
art but knowledge is still hugely
underuse no one reason there is not much
available in form that computers can
consume but just imagine if even this
new models were immediately fed back and
could be an input so it's called closed
loop systems and probably it would be
more intelligent so this is quite
interesting so going back to the 80s the
modus operandi in artificial
intelligence was encoding knowledge into
expert systems because we knew that if
you could encode knowledge you can
deduce new knowledge and new facts from
existing knowledge so knowledge isn't
just data knowledge is one level of of
abstraction higher where you actually
know the relations and you can apply
some kind of functions between data the
problem is it's very brittle uh famously
Doug lennet created this project called
the psych uh project which had millions
and millions of facts and relations and
things in it and it was almost a
complete waste of time it was too
brittle it wasn't particularly useful
but imp Al though we seem to be wasting
our time with this Blank Slate approach
because machine learning moved away from
really any explicit domain knowledge and
it just became these meta priors so
things like symmetries and um I don't
know learning uh learning schedules and
weight Decay and stuff like that and the
the models only had very abstract prior
in the sense of how to learn things
statistically they didn't have any
domain knowledge at all but there are so
many things in our physical world that
we just understand and we should be able
to explicitly code into our system but
we have this Paradox which is that every
time we try and encode high level
knowledge into systems it just
introduces brittleness and this is what
Rich Sutton warned against in his bitter
lescent essay what's the difference for
you between data and
knowledge yes it's a good question and
in different textbooks you actually can
find different definitions but people
who are working in knowledge
representations they have very clear
idea so data facts knowledge it when you
go level up it's like rules
relations ultimately better if you have
models better if you have executable
models so you can put something in get
something out so this is knowledge a lot
of knowledge you can discover directly
from data if you have a lot of data you
can discover this rules you can
construct models but why don't represent
it immediately as knowledge if we
already know it why why it's very
inefficient way it takes a lot of energy
this neural networks they are destroying
the planet and you actually can encode a
lot what we know in quite compact way
and if and you can reuse it a lot what
we know actually is not in the data just
an example I like
my collaborator gave this example like
they were Model in ecological systems
and you can have a lot of data and you
can discover from data that bear has
between two and five cups and if it's
more nose it's less cup but why bother
if we know it just encode it as a
knowledge so you can extract it but you
also can just incote immediately and you
can encode a lot additionally what is
not in the data that is why it's more
powerful and
promising Louisa spoke about a project
about 60 years ago to automate the
scientific discovery of chemical
compounds um not too disimilar actually
to Alpha fold which came out recently
from Deep mine but anyway she's kind of
saying that you know if you look at how
these systems work today it's not
dramatically different than it was 60
years ago what chemist would do and they
put in place a whole pipeline knowledge
acquisition also given output and forms
that this uh good for users in this case
chemists it really produced very
interesting promising chemical structur
moreover this system actually was
multi-agent it was htic dendral metad
dendral and it was closed loop so
whatever it managed to discover it
immediately was going back and improved
over time so it was 60 years ago and I
would claim we haven't progressed much
further of course the other fantastic
systems but the underlying architecture
in and principle how it operate operates
it's still the same so it's called the
robot
scientist and this was introduced again
15 20 years ago
now so the idea is to develop a system
AI system that is capable of generating
hypothesis designing
experiments having real robotic labs to
carry out these experiments analyze
results do it in cycle and hopefully
discover something new so it's a lot of
data external data whatever data sets
are relevant plus internally produced
because it's a robotic lab very powerful
that can run in parallel like 1,000
biologists working in parallel in with
lab but it also has this knowledge
formalized knowledge it has domain
knowledge uh the first system worked
with ye biology but it's also had this
knowledge about what scientific
discovery is what key elements how they
connected what you need to do just like
our experimental practices how to design
experiments you need to explain to mine
it all so in science we need to do
abduction this is absolutely delicious
because you've heard us speak about
abduction ad nausea on mlst and and
Lissa is out there talking about it
which is wonderful but yeah um you have
to start with a hypothesis or a set of
hypotheses in in science before you do
inference right so inference is when you
kind of learn mappings from hypotheses
but abduction is how you first select
the relevant hypotheses right hypotheses
that could generate powerful
explanations for some phenomena and it's
very creative it's very mysterious so
what is the logician 101 definition of
abduction well it's reasoning to the
best
explanation is that helpful maybe maybe
I love the kind of cognitive science
view on things which is you know an
explanation it's a causal model which
helps us understand the world because it
gives explanatory power it carves the
world up by the joints why is the world
this way why is the world not that way
and the raw building materials of these
theories are cognitive priors and
they're the same kind of priors that we
imbue into machine learning models Nome
chsky says that some of these priers are
built into our brains um I'm a big fan
that many of the priers are socially
embedded they're like software that
float around mimetically but anyway
abduction is about you have a bunch of
PRI in a system and we as humans have
this magical ability to grab the
relevant priors stick them together in
into small models that give explanatory
power and selecting a few of those
models and that's what we do when we do
abduction um so the key question is
basically can we automate that in a
machine I will focus on hypothesis
because in philosophy of science for a
long time it was considered that it's
something that you cannot automate so
only humans can do it and uh to enable
this hypothesis generation so you need
to go out of system out of what you
already know so you cannot use uh
conventional logic like deduction you
need to use something else so and used
abduction so there are other logic that
you can use but you need to go outside
of the system so to have these guesses
and then try to see if some of it makes
sense or not it's not trival focusing on
hypothesis so like you want to test
hypothesis at this particular
Gene has that function but you actually
cannot put gene into well or you cannot
measure function so you start doing some
inferences what if we replace it to use
some proxy if we use something with this
gen no out and if we put metabolites and
so you go deeper deeper deeper so
biologist do it just normal practices
but when you try to explain it to
computer how to do it you you really
need to think so what what steps were
were taken we actually very rarely
experiment with something what we make
conclusion about so our conclusions are
not always accurate so then you have to
go back so it was very interesting no
first try to automate it and then also
reflect on how humans are doing science
especially experimental science there
are many levels to this as well so if
you if you want to go and get a job at
Google Now they already have a bit of a
merit ocracy which is based on kind of
what we're talking about here to be very
senior at Google you need to find people
and to be one step below that you need
to find the areas and below that you
need to solve abstract problems and then
below that you need to solve specific
problems so there's a kind of hierarchy
in the amount of creativity and
ambiguity that you can tolerate and
that's what scientists do so they're
always traversing these levels abduction
is about finding the areas and then once
once you perform inference on these
hypothesis that you have abducted then
that's solving a much more specific
problem and it gets more and more
specific the key point is that science
is
combinator exponentially expensive just
to run experiments and there isn't
enough time in the world there aren't
enough scientists in the world yes
having AI scientists can help us but we
still need to always reflexively and
abstractly go one level up we always
need to be asking ourselves the question
can we do this better if we had a
different perspective or a different
view could we make this more efficient
could we make this more efficient and
then could we make this more effici and
that's what we humans can do and that's
what we need to imbue into AI robot
scientists when you need to test like
five six drugs work on this combination
so yes it's combinatoric problem if you
do it in a lab we just don't have enough
cells in our blood to run all this
experiments so this is a justification
when you need such system you first do
reasoning based on all what we know with
all this gaps
contradictions but the best what you can
do output some plausible hypothesis what
should work in this situation then you
can do some simulation again
computational come up with some 100
several hundred hypothesis that then you
can automattic Ally test so that is a
cheaper way of doing it using robotics
yeah so I'm really interested in this
idea of human cyborgs basically where
humans and AIS work together the problem
is it's not easy to say that combining
humans and AIS together produces more
productivity it probably does but we
don't know for sure there was a piece
out by thought Works recently where they
were talking about generative AI or
co-pilot making developers two times
more produ active how do they measure
that right software engineering is not a
reducible activity it's a very complex
phenomenon and people have tried to
measure the productivity of software
Engineers for many years how many lines
of code do they write and you know the
storyboard and issue tracking and stuff
like that it's all rubbish and the
reason for that is it's a very complex
irreducible phenomenon and there in lies
the problem that there's a meme going
around on LinkedIn at the moment talking
about how with co-pilots you can
generate the code 10 times faster but
you then spend 10 times more time
debugging the code and that's because
there's a technical debt a new type of
technical debt understanding debt right
you generated all of this code and it
works and then in order to fix a problem
you need to actually understand it and
the knowledge the mental model is not in
the code actually in any software
engineering project the mental model is
a memetic social thing it's in the
brains of the developers and it kind of
floats around in The Ether it's not in
the code so yeah it's it's a similar
thing here that if we had an AI robotic
scientist how would we know that it's
making us go faster I don't think such
systems will replace human as you see at
the best they can automate some some
signs some uh experiment experimental
driven signs but it's it's important
part of Science and if it can be
automated it will be of great help uh
humans still have distinct advantages in
many areas hopefully we will retain it
but uh ultimately the best way is to
work together take advantage and really
work as a team and then maybe we can
make a faster
progress welcome to mlst so we are here
with Professor Lissa Sova and Lissa
joined goldsmiths in November November
2017 as a director of the the online
Masters in data science program she's an
internationally Rec recognized expert in
artificial intelligence particularly in
Discovery Science reasoning knowledge
representation and semantic Technologies
and Lissa has also been working on the
robot scientist project which
investigates uh which processes of
scientific discovery can be automated
and how robotic and human scientists can
work together and the robot scientist
Adam was the first system which made an
an autonomous scientific discovery she's
also involved in a number of
international projects in the
development of semantic standards for
example the machine learning schema the
robotics task onology standard and um
also the laboratory protocols exact so
um it's a pleasure to have you here
Lissa maybe you could just start off by
telling us about the event and and your
talk today my talk was about the where
we are with anaan science so
yes it's very creative Endeavor to do
science but there are parts of it that
uh scientists try to automate for a long
time so the history of uh scientific
discovery
as subject of computer science it's
actually more than half a century old
and the first systems were developed in
60s in Stanford
[Music]
so the first system it was inspired by
the need to go to other planets collect
samples like if you go to Mars and the
you cannot send the many samples back
mhm uh if you send data so what you
manage to analyze it will take so long
to send it to human scientists to get
some inst instructions what to do next
so that would stimulate the development
of autonomous intelligence systems that
needs to collect something do something
decide what to do next what it means and
um uh since then it was a slow but
steady progress and uh so the system
that we are working on it's already for
over 20 years yes it's called robot
scientist and yes the first was Adam it
actually stand for adaptive machines but
yeah Adam because because it was the
first not not to be confused with the
other adom for um training neuron
networks yes it's a good point so the
principle of such system is that they're
very knowledge intensive so we hear a
lot about progress in EI but it's mostly
data driven
so now we have so much data and also
computational power so it's all can be
processed and something useful
output and I believe that the next step
will be when a lot of knowledge will be
available in a form that computers can
take so right now they're taking data if
we can give our knowledge and let them
to reason with it so that will be
just and do scientific discovery of
course you need to have knowledge
scientists so why is
there still in sh Supply because it
takes like 25 years to
produce one you need to educate it's
many many years of studing and if we can
create systems and also
knowledge
models starting from some domain
knowledge in some particular area so we
are working with
biological system so if you can
encode in machine processible form what
we
know and also in code How We Do Science
so so how we formulate hypotheses of
course not any but at least some it's
actually quite
algorithmic yes what i' I'd love to know
more about that so you said some really
interesting things I mean first of all
as you say if we want to learn about
Mars it's very sample inefficient
because it's very expensive and then we
get to the purpose of Science and in my
opinion the purpose of science is about
generating um intelligible explanations
and then we get to knowledge and I think
you were just alluding to data and
information is not knowledge and I know
you're an expert in knowledge
representation so so perhaps perhaps we
could just touch on does knowledge have
some Primacy over just normal
information Okay so
it's very true that different textbooks
will give different definition and
sometimes there is no distinction
between data information it's like
synonym but yes in my area of research
we very clear about that naturally so
what we consider data is facts yes so
this Gene has this function dark is
bird knowledge is when you go for
so when you have
rules when you have uh like uh even
connections so links between facts you
can go further yes more knowledge model
like uh if you have a lot of data
house prices in this area how it was
affected I don't know by flooding or so
they dropped how much then then you can
can detect this patterns so if you so
this is knowledge so if there is
flooding in area prices will
drop so this is a
rule and you
can represent it in various form
so if we can represent it in forms that
you can put it into memory of computer
then it can be
used and if it can be used together with
data if you have all this components
that it will be even more intelligent
interesting I guess um where I was going
with the question a little bit was also
can knowledge be probabilistic of course
all our knowledge probabilistic we we're
not certain about anything even if we
think yes this is a state of the
art so much knowledge was changed was
refuted so we always work in this
probabilistic framework just we not
always reflect on it but if you want to
build a system that really output
something it is underlining
to so the other side of working on such
system it
the give you a chance to understand
better about what science is like there
are no guaranteed truth it's just what
we believe in at this point given all
data we have and other series who just
work together but it can change in
future yeah it can I mean there's a
couple of things I mean um rationalists
think that there is only certainty you
either know it or you don't and then I
believe that you know basian reasoning
is kind of like the it's an extension of
logical reasoning in the domain of
uncertainty absolutely correct and it's
important to remember about it it's
important to remember even when
uh of course when we read newspapers but
even scientific articles so scientists
actually tend to
overgeneralize or they very excited
about what they discovered it's
important to stand step back and think
that yes it's actually can be refuted it
can be only one explanation
so and if you look at History of Science
just in neonian
physics yeah it looked like the ultimate
truth and then
no theory of relativity turn it all
upside down it's only some fraction of
it yes to to what extent should
knowledge be grounded in the physical
world uh so the whole science it has to
be
verifiable so you you can't
imagine imagine many
things plausible but unless you really
show that this corresponds to
reality we cannot trust it of course it
can be still there can be maybe another
explanation but at least this is
connected to what we observe or even
better if we can design an experiment to
to to show there is something behind it
so this is how s
uh always
worked of course I refer to experimental
science like biology physics where you
can do so are s experiments we will not
go who there so you cannot
build an automated system to do that
interesting I wondered whether you would
Define yourself as a neat or a scruffy
when it comes to knowledge
representation I mean for example if I
Define and by the way an NE is um like a
puritanical
simple underlying principle paron so if
I wanted to define a chair I could think
of thousands of different analogies to
describe a chair do do you is it
collapsible or is it just very
complicated I very NE and I can give you
a perfect example how to model a chair
so I'm very neat because we work with
these reasoning systems and they need
sharp clean logic yes and if you
complicate matters it complicates
reasoning a chance that something will
be really discovered and we want to
connect different bits of knowledge
different data so the more streamline it
is the better and if you use like
minimum of relations and so so over
years I just learn to think that way and
B chair it's actually examples that I
used in my lectures when I was
explaining children so I was showing
them just examples so these are chairs
they can look very differently some
don't have any legs some have three legs
so so how to explain computers this is a
chair yes so you can yes you can
represent one many many many ways but uh
a good knowledge model will focus what
we called intrinsic property MH what
makes it a
chair
give me an example what makes it a chair
it's function to be seated on so it's a
relational model so it was designed it
was produced for
it yeah this is can take many shapes
many colors but this is what defines a
chair so and because we produce it human
so we we can say this is It's function
so and all other yes it can have other
properties like what color it is what
shape but ultimately this what makes it
the chair yes yes because when I hear
philosophers talking about semantics
they they have to come up with some kind
of a relational model and they and they
would choose the view of function or
purpose as another good one and I guess
what I'm saying is it's a little bit
anthropocentric
and like a function for example a
hospital that building used to be a
hospital but it's not a hospital anymore
but again uh why it
is so Centric because it's us who made
it so we have control over it yes it was
hospital now it's no more Hospital some
social convention some decision decision
was made it was repurposed now it is not
hospital it's something else but if you
take biological systems like gin fun
function we have nothing to do with that
it evolved to be there it's still still
it's still intrinsic property of it what
function it has what it's for otherwise
you can we very far like again going
back to a chair I can sit on a table it
doesn't make it a chair because it's not
primarily function this is not what is
was made for yes yes so if you if you
agreed on it you need to have this
Clarity also agreement that this is how
you model things then you start to have
consistency what is a chair what is a
table because if you want to have
intelligence system to design your
office for example so how will it do how
it will distinguish with is word so this
is quite similar in principle to
wienstein said that the the meaning of a
word is in its use and um I'm friends
with a colleague of yours Mark Bishop
who says the meaning of computation is
in its use and but that's a very kind of
relativistic social emergentist kind of
view I guess what I'm saying is do you
think there's a platonic meaning so for
me it's very easy to answer on these
questions because I'm actually working
on development of real systems that need
to take it reason with it and produce
something justification of what we are
doing and how we are doing it works yeah
you can do it differently you can take
different points of view let's design a
different system based on it and then
compare what is better no one has done
it so this is what is done how it's done
it's
working okay okay so but that's very
pragmatic yes I would say it's not
the relativist it's not it's pragmatic
approach to producing knowledge in
machine consumable form it's not optimal
it's not the best but it's something
what good that computers can walk with
and produce something I think he might
be a closet
scruffy um okay are you familiar with
the psych project from Doug lennet I
think so I'm
sure it's almost like preaching to the
choir but um what what kind of
retrospective comments do you have about
that project I think they just attempted
to do too much right so it's like in AI
so this was the constant generic
AI yeah uh versus something practical
fragmented so of course it's wonderful
to have a system that can solve any task
for that you need such know knowledge
models we just not say yet yes maybe in
future right now
we're trying to model some fragments
some domains of knowledge and if we have
enough such fragments hopefully we can
combine but ultimately if you want to
have a general AI you will need such
like interesting more those one contrast
people make is uh I mean I I have
friends who are in the domain of
certainties they think knowledge is
either you know it or you didn't and the
reason that they give and the reason why
they don't like language model is
because they say well when you have
actual knowledge so you actually know
you can deduce new facts and new
knowledge so you can you can create more
knowledge and they would say with a
language model because it's only
pretending to reason you can't create
any new knowledge with
it it's actually an advantage we already
started using it to generate hypothesis
yes because it's not rigid uh deduction
it is how you can actually make new
guesses and then some of them might be
true you just need to experiment to show
it so we already started we generated
some very interesting hypothesis where
we already organizing experiments to
test them yes um I I believe that
science is about abduction you know so
like creating this plausible set of
hypotheses and we're at an event all
about creativity and have that spark of
inspiration don't they they we just have
an idea about plausible hypotheses and
maybe maybe the world is quite sclerotic
and predictable and boring but do you
think that there's some spark that we
won't get from a uh I completely agree
with you and it's exactly what we use we
use abduction in our reasoning system to
generate hypothesis yes so in some
simple uh application areas like uh in
drug design you use induction you just
have many many many examples with
chemical structures showed activity so
you can if you see similar structure you
indu it it might show similar activity
again it's not always so this is still
it's not you cannot INF ultimate truth
that is why you need experiments but
abduction yes this is something what
takes you outside of what you already
know yes yes I I completely agree I
think it's the most exciting
part and but again this is
um what is
technological so there are reasoners
they can do abductions there are
languages
that can handle it so we have many
building blogs to build such system yes
yes and um are you excited about the
prospect of neuros symbolic
architectures or are you still very old
school and and you like these explicit
knowledge
representations that is a different
difficult question so yes I'm very
excited by what is happening I I was
skeptical about all these natural
language process and we Tred to walk
with NLP people and results always were
quite disappointing how much useful
information they actually could extract
and then such Li such progress so of
course it is exciting and we already
starting using it
in our scientific work so it's the same
time I believe there is a place for this
very clean crisp models just because you
you need something as simple as possible
just to enable reasoning
MH just because all this reasoning
engines they are powerful but if they
can reason over simpler structur so
there is more chances they will do it
exactly better so for for the for for
practical uh purposes from all my
experience the cleaner you can get it
the better it works but ultimately when
we have more technological progress then
we probably will be able more reflect
the how it is in our brain yes but
there's also robustness and reliability
and trustworthiness precisely so you
actually then can explain how it was
done so this explainability it's all
trust so if people understand how it
works if we can explain this is how it
happened this is what was taken as input
this is how
it was done and people will trust it
more and especially like systems that we
are working like applications for cancer
research what What doctor would
recommend this uh drugs if they don't
understand how this system came up with
this suggestions yes yes so and again
the cleaner your representations the
easier to explain it I know I I really
agree with you the only intuition I have
is that if we're designing a novel
molecule for example even if we knew or
could understand how it was
created would we really understand
it it seems so complicated doesn't it it
is it is um but again there are
different Logics so for example fzy
logic you can build system around that
so ultimately let let's try to build
more such systems and then you just
force to understand so if you can build
it then you understand how it's working
yes
inevitably so I still believe that some
portion important portion of this can be
modeled something probably not in any
near future this just too complex too
fuzzy Lissa it's been an absolute honor
how can people find out more about you
and and what you're up
to we actually very bad with telling
about what we are doing that is why I'm
so glad that you invited me to talk
about it we just bued in our walk and
the best we will publish our scientific
papers and it is very
stop Yes you teach student you tell
students it's based on your research you
use examples but apart from that we
don't do much and really
quite quite K to change it I know I I
think a lot of people are intimidated by
papers and Science and if only people
knew how many fascinating ideas there
are in there I think they just need a
hook and yeah it's it's so interesting
no I blame scientist they keep this
complicated language even if sometimes
they don't need it so they just they
keep people away from it yes indeed no I
I think scientist should do more about
explaining their work how they're doing
it I always thought that we do our work
someone else
will solve all that AI
Associated problems but no it's actually
us who have to do it and explain and
tell and also
warn yeah well now people can ask GPT
for but what it generates it's not
allice
correct that's true it's not but it's um
it's quite good it's good it's very
impressive it's very impressive yeah
it's quite good Lissa has been an honor
thank you so much thank you thank you
very much my pleasure my pleasure I'm so
impressed by how much you know and
understand wow oh yeah how many people
around know Abduction come on oh we are
a computer science podcast I think it's
one of the most fundamental things in
cuz you know um going back to Aristotle
um you know with the the weak syllogisms
and the strong syllogisms and and you
know I I I think of um induction is
actually quite interesting because most
people use it to include abduction um so
not only creating the map to the
hypothesis space but actually um you
know abduction is just creating the
plausible I completely agree because if
you're clear about it so you're clear
about logic so you can have fuzzy
concept all this probabilistic but
underline logic must be
you need to understand and if it's
abduction precisely it's only with some
probability that it's correct